Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
en esta ocasión estamos con el ciclista
colombiano Sergio higuita en el 2022 fue
campeón nacional en ruta de Colombia
ganó también la clasificación general de
la vuelta a Cataluña corre actualmente
en el equipo alemán Bora Hans y hoy
recibe en la ciudad colombiana de
bucaramanga en el marco de los
campeonatos nacionales de ruta
2023 Sergio Muchas gracias por
atendernos hoy en France 24 Hola a todos
Muchas gracias por la invitación aquí a
Flans 24 muy feliz de estar acá con
ustedes y nada saludarlos a todos con un
saludo muy grande especial pues Sergio
es un placer estar aquí contigo junto a
todo lo que he comentado antes usted
ganó también una etapa en la vuelta al
algarve en el año 2022 hizo realmente
buenos resultados en las clásicas
italianas y junto a todo eso fue el
mejor ciclista del continente americano
y el número 12 del ranking Mundial de la
unión ciclista internacional que usted
ve todo esto que cree que el pequeño
niño del barrio Castilla de Medellín
pensaría cuando ve que ha conseguido
tantas victorias a sus 25 años Yo creo
que
es algo soñado yo primeramente me soñaba
estar corriendo en un equipo World tour
se me dio y ya luego con el esfuerzo del
sacrificio que he hecho durante todo
estos años la disciplina con el amor que
le he metido a este deporte le he
entregado toda mi vida este deporte
desde que era muy niño Yo creo que es
algo que he ganado por tanto esfuerzo
que he hecho Y de verdad que
ese niño yo cuando era muy niño o sea lo
hacía todo con mucha convicción en el
ciclismo
era un camino muy largo porque hay veces
llegas hay veces no afortunadamente
puede llegar y el camino se me ha venido
abriendo y feliz de haber podido
conseguir esos estos resultados tan
importantes para mí
todo lo que le conocen como ciclista
dicen que tiene unas cualidades muy
buenas casi perfectas para las clásicas
de un día es usted explosivo no es tan
común eso dentro del ciclismo colombiano
el año pasado Sin embargo tuvo ciertos
problemas de salud que no le impidieron
estar en su mejor momento en estas
clásicas le veremos en este año 2023
ganar una de estas etapas estas clásicas
de las ardenas esperemos que sí me hacen
mucha ilusión hacer estas clásicas de
las ardenas Esperemos que la salud y
todo la suerte y todos nos acompaña y
viendo todo esto donde cree que está su
límite y Qué gran carrera le encantaría
ganar
el límite yo creo que se lo plantea uno
mismo yo creo que uno no debe tener
límites ni mentales ni físico ni pensar
que porque uno es pequeño o es muy
grande o pesa más o es muy delgado
plantearse límites sino trabajar hacerlo
con el corazón siempre dar el 100% y ya
la carrera lo pone en el sitio que está
Yo creo que un gran sueño mío sería
ganar un Campeonato del mundo
y una clásica pensaría que sería
perfecto para mí Creo que me estoy
acercando cada año más a este objetivo
Espero que no se quede en palabras sino
que se puede hacer realidad algún día
bueno y usted en el mundo del ciclismo y
ya es un corredor muy respetado en todo
el mundo pero especialmente aquí en
Colombia con la responsabilidad que yo
conlleva en un país que vive tan
intensamente el ciclismo no cómo siente
usted la presión siente más la presión
por parte de su equipo o por ser quizás
ese relevo tan esperado en el ciclismo
colombiano se siente presión de las dos
partes pienso que uno debe saber manejar
eso
el primer año que sentí mucha presión
fue cuando gané el Campeonato nacional
ese primer año
logré ganar
siendo campeón nacional del tour
Colombia
pero luego en Europa tenía mucha presión
de que debía ganar en Europa esa tercera
en París Niza o luego cuando volvimos de
la pandemia fue un desastre y sentí
demasiada presión mediática de
que ya no rendía de que di un
rendimiento ya no voy a volver a estar
donde eran y son cosas que no aprende a
manejar y se vuelven experiencias Pero
al final claro nosotros tenemos una gran
responsabilidad ahora
Especialmente los que somos del 97 98 y
99 que es digamos de las cámaras de las
últimas quemadas que estamos en el
borutour todos que son Bernal
Sosa Martínez Rubio Harold Tejada
buitrago Todos hemos corrido juntos la
misma categoría y
Entonces yo creo que no solo yo sino que
todos sentimos una gran responsabilidad
porque
nairo rico Chávez
atapuma pantano han conseguido y muchos
más que Sergio Luis Henao
no sé si se me escapará alguno de esta
otra camada
consiguieron un gran muy grande
resultados ganar grandes vueltas ganar
etapas en altura en la vuelta en el giro
Entonces
nosotros alcanza responsabilidad pero
nada la asumimos con mucho amor Bueno
habla de usted de la generación anterior
de la suya en la anterior aparecen
nombres como nairo Quintana Miguel Ángel
López de los que se ha hablado mucho por
las polémicas de los últimos meses se
habla también de que no hay relevo de la
mala situación del ciclismo colombiano
cree usted que realmente está tan mal el
ciclismo de Colombia
yo pensaría que
no está tan mal porque ahora Nosotros
somos el relevo que está ahí que está
ahora que se va a madurar en 10 años
pero si en cinco años no empiezan a
llegar chicos que estén tres cuatro
cinco años en el World tour que sean del
2001 del 2002 2004 ahí sí va a haber una
preocupación porque ahora nosotros vamos
a poder rendir 10 o 12 años más pero de
allí fue allí debe haber otra relevo
pienso que se debe trabajar ya mismo los
ciclistas jóvenes que van a tener que
dar ese relevo porque al final si
nosotros desaparece cuando nos retiremos
no sé con 38 35 37 años y no hay un
relevo si va a pasar una brecha iba a
ser difícil volver a llegar al ciclismo
europeo porque está teniendo un gran
nivel y nosotros nos tenemos que adaptar
a ellos y trabajar desde las bases en
eso en todos casi que todos los que con
los que yo he estado
de esa generación Tuvimos una formación
muy parecida
entonces esperemos que se vuelva a dar
eso pero
pienso que también es muy secuencial el
ciclismo en los países en ciclismo muy
giratorio pienso que es muy secuencial
pero sí que él seguimos colombiano de
aprender año tras año porque somos una
potencia y tenemos las condiciones para
hacer grandes ciclistas y que cree que
le falta al ciclismo de Colombia para
seguir exportando calidad ciclistas de
calidad hacia Europa que se ha hecho mal
hasta ahora lo que pienso yo es que lo
que pasó es que llega Bernal van al Tour
de Francia el giro de Italia hace cosas
muy importantes
Igualmente Martínez
todos los esos todos los que somos de
esta cama ganan etapas están ahí también
figurando también con nairo y Rigo todo
ciclistas de mi camadas hemos hecho
todos escuela en mi caso yo estuve en
continental luego en continental pro y
luego en worl
no me cogieron de un inmediato para el
World tour porque yo sé que si yo
hubiera pasado algo le hubiera reventado
porque no sé era un niño de 19 años que
llegaba a Europa la primera vez que
llegué a Europa Para mí fue difícil
estar cuatro meses lejos de mi familia
está con todo el equipo y todos éramos
colombianos y aún así se hacía difícil
entonces no quiero imaginar un chico que
llegó un equipo World tour que los
equipos World tour son independientes
tienes que llegar como la universidad
tienes que llegar al examen y ganarlo tú
vas allí y tienes que pagarte Ya tu
apartamento vivir solo ser muy
profesional Y eso se debe aprender año
tras año madurar todo todo que pase todo
para poder Así que que suceda y ahora
hubieron muchos chicos que los estuve
los cogieron los llevaron allí al World
tour y digamos no hicieron esta escuela
y es importante Entonces yo pensaría que
yo creo que esa sería la base darle
tiempo a los chicos que maduran pero ya
los jóvenes a Europa pero
de a poco y al hilo de todo lo que está
contando usted viene de un origen
humilde como muchos de los ciclistas
históricamente en Colombia cree que
tanto los ciclistas colombianos como los
suramericanos deben hacer más
sacrificios que los europeos para llegar
a la élite Sí en realidad económicamente
si el sacrificio en entrenamiento está
igual por parte que entrenar y sufrir
bastante pero digámoslo así Hubo un
tiempo en que yo era un niño y yo salía
a entrenar y hay veces se me
pinchaba la bici y me tenía y no tenía
repuesto de un para poder volver a
llegar bien a la casa o salía a entrenar
y mañana algo de la bicicleta y era en
un repuesto de una bicicleta de ciclismo
y hoy en día es carísimo en ese tiempo
era costoso ahora vendía más entonces
mucha gente me regalaba a mí componentes
de la bicicleta me regalaba cascos
zapatillas para ir a competir Igualmente
me regalaban el hospedaje me regalaban
la alimentación o sea estuve demasiado
apoyado y eso que mi papá tenía dos
trabajos él iba a trabajar en una
empresa en la noche volví a trabajar
cerrajería en la casa y mi madre también
venía vendía productos de
lociones cremas así por catálogos y aún
así no no alcanzaba para el ciclismo
alcanzaba para algunas cosas pero no
para todo pero digámoslo así gracias a
Dios tuve el apoyo de mucha gente que
veía en mí yo era un niño que tenía
muchas ganas de salir adelante con este
deporte o sea este era fue mi primer
amor Entonces yo era muy enfocado muy
disciplinado todo todo como un alemán
cuadradito entonces la gente vio ese
interés y me apoyaban Por esa razón y
también porque un barrio humilde y así
fue hice mucho sacrificios muchos
también lo hacen
es imaginable acá o por ejemplo un
ejemplo cuando fuimos a Argentina allí
los europeos o los alemanes veían las
clases y decían Uy cómo es posible que
vivan aquí en Suramérica de esa manera
yo le dije no esto es normal pero
también yo creo que nosotros somos así
por lo que nos ha tocado vivir somos
aguerridos y clima disciplinados todo
porque sabemos lo difícil que es
conseguir cosas entonces por eso yo creo
que también somos
deportistas de tan buen nivel porque
sabemos que para ganar algo y que
sacrificarse y dar el 200%
bueno Sergio ya para acabar yo he podido
leer en la descripción suya de la página
web de su equipo el Bora Hans que dice
que la música es alegría para el alma
Qué representa para Sergio veguita para
el alma de Sergio vegetal ciclismo
yo creo que para mi alma significa todo
o sea es por lo que me muevo es por lo
que cada día amanezco
es Digamos como decimos en Colombia que
nos está dando hoy en día la comida toda
mi familia el techo todo y es mi gran
amor yo cada vez que monto en bicicleta
me siento libre me siento feliz hay días
malos pero me pongo a analizar y digo no
disfrutemos de cada día porque soy un
bendecido al ir en bicicleta y ganarme
la vida de esta manera siento ciclista
entonces para mí significa el todo o sea
el ciclismo para mí es mi alma yo lo
diría así pues es que muchas gracias por
esta entrevista ha sido un placer estar
contigo y le deseo que tenga un buen
campeonato de Colombia y una buena
temporada 2023 esperemos que sea así
Muchas gracias a todos un saludo muy
grande
[Música]